So, here's the empty shell of our program. We'll need a scanner to read the
user input, but right now the code won't compile. It doesn't know what a
scanner is. We need to import java.util.Scanner to tell the program where to
find the code for the scanner. That's better. Now, we want to print the prompt.
And I remember my colon and space at the end. So that there would be space for
the user input and I now read in the word. I'm going to use the next line, I'll
explain that in another minute. I'll make my book so that I can use it to do
the calculations. And now, I can calculate the number of occurrences and print
the result in a nice format. I'm safe I made any syntax errors with all that
typing. Sure enough, misspelled occurrences. Thank goodness for the compiler.
You saw this run before, so I won't run it again. There is that one question
left over though. The next versus nextline. Let's look at the documentation. If
I search for scanner and Java 7, go to the official documentation, and then
search for the methods. Here they are, there are a lot of them, but here are
the ones that start to be nextFloat. And next, nextBigDecimal. All right. The
ones that return strings are next, next with a pattern, next with another
pattern. Next line, all right. And these look like something else. nextLine has
slightly awkward language. Advances this scanner past the current line and
returns the input that was skipped. But what this means for us is that the
scanner will give us a line of input. So, everything the user types before they
hit Enter will get loaded in with next. If I find the documentation for next
without the line. Here's next. It says finds and returns the next complete
token from this scanner. Wants a complete token. Maybe there's more
information. It says, a complete token is preceded and followed by input that
matches the delimiter pattern. And then, talks about blocking while waiting for
input to scan. You don't need to worry about that part too much. Basically,
it's saying it'll wait until the user actually enters something. But this
delimiter thing, maybe somewhere on this page it says what the delimiter is.
Let's look for it using Ctrl+F. Delimiter. This looks like it's in the summary
near the top of the page. A scanner breaks its input into tokens using a
delimiter pattern, which by default, matches whitespace. We saw whitespace
before, that was things like spaces and tabs that you can't see. I guess that
makes sense. So, it gives you a chunk that is separated from other things by
something like spaces. So, it seems like next would work fine by default if the
user just wanted to search for one word, like Alice. But if they wanted to
search for two words, like Mad Hatter, you would want to use nextLine.